i think she shut the blinds so that he
wouldn't see us walking up
i'm really nervous
hi i'm riya
cooking and giving food can be a
personal and wonderful gift this holiday
season we wanted to help two of our
friends say thank you to some very
important people in their lives
here are their stories this is my friend
krista she's a good fall producer so i
don't need to be here to teach you
anything
today really is going to be teaching me
how to make my dad's favorite oatmeal
raisin cookies which i've actually never
made before but i feel like i'm in good
hands the reality for me is that i
wouldn't be here today if it weren't for
a police chief who adopted me when i was
11. it's such an honor to help me help
you to make cookie for your dad i heard
your story earlier it's very
i got a little bit emotional i'm excited
to present them to him i'm rachel today
i am teaming up with riya to make my
aunt betsy's favorite cookies which are
chocolate chip cookies without the
chocolate chips when my mom was becoming
very sick me and my dad were very lost
betsy had gotten wind of this
and decided to drop everything and come
over to the east coast i felt
safer so have you made this cookie
before i barely made cookies but i've
definitely never made this one whenever
you have a question stop me and ask me
questions mostly you're gonna make it
put the butter in a pot
holding it whole thing okay get in there
so you are going to shift together
flour
and everything else into that shifter
flour yeah
baking soda
cinnamon
i was born into a family that
unfortunately was riddled with addiction
for a single guy in his 50s to take on
an 11 year old kid
is astounding all right what's next and
a salt and a great nutmeg perfect so so
it's like a quarter teaspoon okay
you start seeing the brown beets right
yeah yeah that's the flavor can you pour
it
oh god no no no you're gonna add water
until
one cup mark
nice so i'm going to put in a
refrigerator because it's really really
hot so i'm going to cool it down to the
next step betsy had come into the house
and provided dinner for me on nights
when i didn't want to eat she would
bring me to the local mall and help me
get clothes for school there were things
that usually me my mom would do but my
mom was too sick to do at this point
today i'm really excited because i'm
going to be able to finally give betsy a
special gift put flour
baking soda okay
make it rain next step is creaming
butter so just put it in a bowl and
sugar both sugar
castor sugar and brown sugar
use a hand
cream until it's kind of like a facial
cream texture
it's really important to me to be able
to show my dad how much i appreciate him
every year at christmas he writes me a
handwritten letter telling me how proud
he is of me and how far i've come in my
life i feel like this might be a good
way to kind of give that back to him
this is brown sugar this one's okay
sugar so brown sugar makes cookie a
little bit chewy another secret
ingredient is espresso powder it's kind
of like
break sweetness okay and salt
and what's the vanilla extract
it's for flavor too i thought it was
like molasses oh
is that what molasses looks like melissa
is a little thicker
because it's molasses next step is add
all meals and mix with spatula
we want to make a little bit you know
elevated yeah a little bit special um
have some toasted walnuts i have
dried cherries and cranberries that
sounds really good and i feel like
with the different berries it'll give it
sort of a holiday vibe as well yeah it's
a little bit red color so it's kind of
give a nice holiday spirit i think so we
chilled brown butter i smell it smell it
oh my god pour this over okay and scrape
all the goodies on the bottom in here
don't be scared you can go a little
faster if you want
higher yeah
i got you
nice
and i'm going to add dry ingredients you
shifted earlier so just um scoop
and drop
we are going to flatten this a little
bit on your hand
one inch
apart or whatever okay
so we are going to pop this in a
refrigerator for one hour to chill
and bake for 12 to 40 minutes
so ta-da whoo yeah
it smells so good really good i like the
nice golden crunchy edge i really hope
you're that little like it i think he's
gonna really love this i like these a
lot and i know him pretty well
so i think he's gonna really enjoy these
this is great yeah i like so much oh
yeah great you did it it's like the
perfect consistency
i think she's gonna love them yeah the
best part of baking and cooking for
somebody else what are you doing that
you're thinking about that person yeah
you're taking time you know going
shopping and making and baking whole
time it's dedicated to that person yeah
and i think that time is precious
i'm here about two and a half hours
outside of la just to surprise my dad
with these cookies
um i even found this little box with
dinosaurs on it which i thought was
super cute because his name is rex i
invited my aunt betsy to the studio
today she doesn't really know what's
happening so i'm really excited and also
a little bit nervous to give her this
gift so we'll ask us
[Music]
betsy i brought you here today to talk
about my mom and all the things that
occurred
almost 15 years ago now but what i did
not tell you is the video is actually
about you and i wanted to say thank you
and i never got a chance to and i am so
sorry for that but i wanted to reach out
to you
and
especially around the holidays i gotta
go get this
bring you oh my god
your favorite cookies the chocolate chip
cookies without chocolate chips and just
to tell you that i'm thinking of you you
did so much for me and i
so appreciate that because you really
changed the course of my life
hi dad hey sweetie how are you doing
here
i brought you a box of your favorite
cookies
don't mind them these are your favorite
cookies
and basically i just wanted to bring
them to you i made them
especially for you because i know that
they're your favorite and i wanted to do
it as a way to say thank you for
just having to cry for just being so
important to me just being me yeah for
just being you
and for being so
amazing to me and and supporting me and
loving me
and for being my dad you're welcome
thank you thank you i don't feel like i
really didn't you did but i wanted to
i love you very much
you adopted me
and because of that my life is so much
better
and
[Music]
my life is so much
better and i appreciate it every day
i do too
they're very good your mom would be
really proud you're a very
very unique young woman thank you yeah
we had a rough spot for a little but i'm
okay now no you're good you know how
much i love you
i know
every time i talk to you every time i
see you it's always the same
love is always there
mean you yep
well thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
you